let's say that every time you invited a
friend out for lunch they turned up late
or didn't turn up at all they didn't
text back they just kept not holding to
their word after a while you wouldn't
believe in them you wouldn't be friends
with them and you'd stop inviting them
out to lunch you are that friend to
yourself how on Earth do you think that
you're going to be able to move
mountains and get out of that
relationship that you don't like and
move countries or change career when you
can't not hit snooze even though last
night you promised yourself that you
won't going to hit snooze it's how
people that are able to do extraordinary
things have been able to get there that
they've just started off unbelievably
small I'm just not going to hit the
snooze button I'm just not going to use
my phone before 9:00 a.m. Mark Manson
quote here is the person you have to
spend the most time listening to in your
life is yourself try not to lose their
respect self-respect and self-esteem I
think largely comes from having faith in
your own words